what do you not expect to see on
Footwear how about moles or alligators
or actual skulls prepare to drop your
jaw in shock at the 10 most bizarre
shoes on Pinterest and if you're new to
our channel hit the red button down
below to subscribe
reverse high heels why wear a pair of
high heels the right way around when you
can wear them back to front don't worry
about the fact that you'll have to lean
forward to get your balance or that
you'll get serious cramping you're
strangely bent legs it's not really
surprising that the designer of these
heels leave and Reviver names them it's
scary beautiful well the scary part we
can understand but beautiful more like
painful no shoe heels one of the things
we all expect from a pair of shoes is
that they're full shoes shoes have soles
but this pair of heels is made from
little more than just heels or metal
screws digging into your heels to be
precise and a thin metal chain draping
to the front of the foot and a strap
around the ankle wondering what that
blingy beat stands for we reckon it's
short for bizarre circle shoes walking
on flat shoes is so last season in the
future we'll all be walking around on
curves so get ahead of the trend by
donning a pair of ring shoes designed by
Peter pops these shoes look like the
sort of bouncy pair you'd wear on the
moon that makes sense given that they
were influenced by sci-fi and 1960s
space-age design and they were inspired
by our future locomotion and magnetic
transportation whatever that means
Scola toes when shoes an art collide you
can find some seriously bizarre Footwear
like Stephen Cohen skele-toes most of us
will get a shiver down our spines when
we see the artists skull heeled shoes
not only must they be seriously
uncomfortable to wear but they would
also give us the creeps in a piece of
performance art called Golgotha the
creator walked down Wall Street and
Times Square wearing the skull stilettos
that must have given the bankers and
tourists a fright the eyes have it
fashion we can often present weird and
wonderful Footwear and none more so than
these colorful eyes shoes
surely the front row felt like they were
being watched by something pretty creepy
when these platforms stopped down the
runway they were parted the ESM OD
graduate collection at China Fashion
Week spring summer 2013 presentation
pom-poms and bright circles are strange
enough but it's the bloodshot eyes that
really make them bizarre to get to our
shoes why hold the guitar in your hands
when you can wear one on your feet
that's what performance art group chicks
on speed thought when they created these
playable guitar shoes with shoe designer
max Coubertin they use technology to
combine art fashion and music for their
residency at Dundee Contemporary Art the
wearer can actually play the shoes
without having any cables connected as
the high heels have a wireless trigger
of guitarists apples smoking shoes a
cigarette is certainly something you
don't expect to see on shoes so that's
what designer fam perv all stuck on to a
pair of black pumps along with a hand
curled around the toe of the shoes the
smoking pair was part of the norwegians
collection called sooner or later
another bizarre pair in this 2011
collection is called hens which has two
big hands with red painted nails
gripping the heels you'd definitely turn
heads walking in this Blacky Footwear
make it snappy we've all heard of shoes
made from the skin of exotic animals and
they tend to look just like normal shoes
but when a designer takes it to a
literal level you end up with a really
weird pair like alligator shoes that are
in the shape of actual alligators some
have the head sticking right off the
front of the toes others have the jaws
snapping back up the wearer's legs
whichever way they are designed they all
have one thing in common they're utterly
bizarre mole shoes if you've ever had
corns bunions or blisters on your feet
you might have tried moleskin padding to
help ease the pain and it seems a shoe
designer has had some fun with the idea
of mole skin and feet and created a pair
of slip ons that resemble the cute
creature that lives underground sure a
mole skin looks soft and furry but
surely nobody would want to wear actual
moles on their soles
just imagine the sound of their tiny
claws tapping each time you took a step
freaky sweet treats there are plenty of
us who love shoes and love cake and shoe
bakery has capitalized on this by
creating foot
it looks just like deserts their cake
sponge wedges and heels look so
realistic they've even included a
warning on their website they make a
point of letting customers know their
products are not edible but our wearable
works of art it might sound like a joke
but Chris Campbell is selling these cute
confections for hundreds of dollars a
pair which of these shoes is the most
bizarre let us know in the comments and
remember to give us a big thumbs up
[Music]